so how is life in quarantine for you
have you been adjusting to this this new
normal you know I have to say kind of
great for me I mean we have three kids
that are all you know we have about 17
year old 15 year old 12 year old but so
everyone's home we're not running around
at soccer games and plays and you know
play date so it's been kind of nice I
mean then first I have to say the first
seven weeks were right run week eight
and I'm about to lose my mind but for
the most part it's been great it's been
a real real testament as to who your
kids are and and how you raised them and
so it's been somewhat rewarding yeah I
saw that that video you posted of your
family friend Pocono
oh my god I cry how did I come together
yeah it was so the day she I mean she
was coming back from her last chemo
visit and her mom sort of sent out an
emergency hey it would be great if
everyone could line the streets and so
it kind of spread like wildfire through
the community and you know we live in
Pasadena it's a pretty tight-knit
community and so we lined up and we were
all on the side of the road and cheering
and that the point of view was from
inside the car and afterwards you know
April walked around with a mask on and
social distancing was just coming into
sort of our understanding lexicon and
she said I just wish people could see
how amazing this experience was for I
just wish people could celebrate her and
I said we'll give it to me I'll you know
I'll tweet it and we'll see what happens
and cut to you know the entire world
ended up tuning in and you know from
John John Krasinski and Ellen DeGeneres
and the world just sort of like was took
to that story like they needed that so
it was really an amazing thing for them
as a family to sort of be celebrated for
a second
so your guest starring in in the show
bark skins coming up yeah I love up I
love like a pier
a piece for you I love the look I'm
gonna start to move through my house
give my entire family home hi everyone
yeah bark skin it's great it's you know
for me I got a chance to work with one
of my my favorite people in this
industry and some names I would read the
creator he did a show I did a couple
years ago called the bridge and working
with him as a privilege I think that he
sees me as an actor like other people
don't and you know he gave me an
opportunity to come along and play sort
of a heavy and you know 1600 Quebec and
it was awesome I had to do things I just
never get a chance to do in this
business so it was great yeah what was
your favorite thing about tapping into
to that type of role well it's a
challenge I mean you know plant I played
Dean on good girls on NBC and I think I
go to work and sort of it's not it's you
know two degrees away from home at Lille
ER it is and it's not like you're making
huge choices it's quiet quiet but yeah
so it's a little different than and
having a chance to the idea of being
able to do other things I Christ house
tour continues you you mentioned good
girls because that you guys kind of got
impacted by the cove in 19 do you you I
mean how do you feel about how the
season ended this time and is there
anything that you think will kind of
carry over into the next season if there
is one yeah yeah the I think your
chances are really good to come back we
have heard anything specifically at
where it's a relatively severe II
successful show on all platforms for NBC
so that's great and look you know our
season finale was episode 12 out of the
16 episode season so it was a smack dab
in the middle of everything building
so I'm excited about where it's going I
mean that we have I think that when we
start next season we'll continue and
finish out what we have planned for the
seas and then go right into Mexican but
look I think the show is it's one of
those shows that it's like shits
creaking away it's growing by not in
popularity because people are finding is
people have gotten have been given a
chance to find it on any platform
whether to Lou whether it's NBC you
whether it's you know internationally
with with Netflix all these elements you
know allow people to get to it and the
show's find me its rhythm like like a
show takes a second to sort of find its
tone actors take it second to sort of
figure out the characters and now I
think we're in a really sweet spot with
the storytelling and I'm just a big
scream daddy one of my favorite you see
your scream daddy yes all right
I don't know I you know it's my worst
happens to say daddy all the time I'm
waiting for someone who needs me to feel
like know our daddies but there are
there are there are things going around
about a screen five I know student
exactly making out but there's also
theories about you know if Stu lived
what do you think about a screen five
just because it's kind of weird without
Wes Craven's being around yeah sure
I think he's give me complicated I don't
know I mean I don't know much about it I
I know that it's happening I'm three I
know red similar stories and I don't
know who then I don't know who's out I
don't know if it's a reboot look I think
any time huh it better not be a reboot I
just know I want this franchise yeah
it's good and I think they've got a
really caught me I think that when you
stay with them you say with Sidney
Prescott I think you're doing
I don't know you're getting a chance to
do something nobody else ever did like
everyone was so interesting and we
creating something
I think they would be fools to walk away
from that I think she's awesome I think
that people love to root for her
generation after generation so yeah but
I think it look I think it's it takes
the right person to come in and fill
those shoes and I think you can see that
with the Star Wars franchise like you
can either do it right or you can do it
and you just hope that somebody that you
know started a franchise and and
believes in it you know my hope is that
they do it right and I I'd be surprised
they've never seen done something yeah
and and didn't have the right sort of
love and take on it and a smart take and
I don't think she would do something
just for the sake of if somebody came to
you and was like we have a like this
idea for you to come back in some way
yeah I wouldn't want to be I mean look
we are we are actors you know for the
most part most of us are out here at tap
dancing it's best we can to feed their
families and get jobs so if there was a
good chance to come back that made sense
yes I mean you know originally I was
supposed to be the killer and scream 3 I
do not think I knew that yeah scream 3
was originally conceived at Stu was
running a collection of kids in high
school that did horrible things and
right before we went into production
Columbine High School broke down and the
world changed and so they changed the
scripting and Stu is not in it so I
would like to argue on behalf of Steve
guys out there that he is still alive
there's like things that you were in
cameos in like 2 & 4 but then I look at
the footage and I'm like I can't even
tell if that's no no I I was in two
because I was visiting all my friends
and I walked to the back of a party sit
yeah well that's rumor starting right
there
it's time we made our new movie well I
gotta say I um you know no disrespect to
Will Forte but I feel like it's very odd
that there's a scooby-doo movie coming
out without us shaggy you are shaggy
you've been shaggy since Casey Kasem
retired right yes how you feel about how
you feel about Scoob are you a Scoob
daddy as well or just scream daddy I'm
definitely I mean I'm a scream daddy
daddy's are you like an allegation I
love a beer
Star Wars daddy for sure scream daddy
yeah about scuba good things to say I
wish them all well yeah yeah
understandable discipline yeah maybe I
was a drag yeah and I was surprised that
happened and I think Hollywood's a very
you know all I was an interesting place
and I've been around for a long time and
some of them are easier to accept than
others when you don't get a job there's
not one that was a bummer I like playing
the part I like sort of having a legacy
and a career that's been 30 years you
know I'm doing it so I like the fact
that I was that part and being it was it
was a bummer that was a different way
yeah what are you a daddy yes uh what am
i I'm a dungeon dragon daddy yeah we
know Ben you know we started out my five
best friends and I started a company
called fetal ngrams
that produces Dungeons & Dragons stuff
we've been playing since we were 21 I'm
50 and so yeah so we started that like
yes three years now and now you know and
so now I'm like inundated in the world
of D&D like I never thought I would be
but it's awesome
my partner's a big D&D person I've never
oh yeah he like oh oh it's great you
should jump in it's just like it's
intimidating to jump in for the first
time because yeah but it's the best I
mean it's animate it's literally just
sitting around and telling
story and it's all the sort of great
aspects of that tradition that we as a
culture love and thrive on and just told
and like with the parameter of rules
that helps guide the outcome it's really
it's an awesome way to spend the life
it's on my list I try maybe I'll be a
D&D daddy you know there you go
[Music]